[SOFT MUSIC PLAYING]
Woo.
Aren't we having a super
fun time on our trip
to Pleasant Valley farm.
Yeah.
[SOFT MUSIC PLAYING]
Ready?
Steady?
Let's go.
There must be
something in the way.
[ROARING]
[SCREAMING]
Warning.
This movie contains
flesh-eating zombies,
assault with a deadly
guitar, [SHATTERING GLASS]
strong language.
Fuck.
Douche bag?
Stop fucking swearing.
Firearms, [GUNSHOTS]
disembowelment, death metal,
gore, mini golf, Conga lines,
space aliens, and Academy
Award winner Lupita Nyong'o.
[THUMPING] [SCREAMING]
That might be a little
much for everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CRYING]
[THUMPING]
[GRUNTING] How do
you like it, huh?
Oh, God.
What have I done?
[BELL RINGING]
(SINGING) Players gonna
play, play, play, play, play.
Little Monsters.
(SINGING) And the haters gonna
hate, hate, hate, hate, hate.
Rated R.
(SINGING) I just wanna shake,
shake, shake, shake, shake.
Shake it off.